question one
the function is y equals five x squared
minus x can i get some agreement does
that look good as a derivative
yeah i'm happy with that i gave you a
nice gentle uh ease in you choose to
turn by term that two multiplied by five
reduce it by one everything looks good
i'm really happy i'm not gonna dwell on
that at all
when you have a look at question two you
get given inside the bracket something
very similar to question one
but we raise it to this seventh power
and raising it to such a high power
means i really don't want to expand this
i mean in theory you could
but you know like the sun would set and
you'd want to eat dinner and you're like
i don't have time for this right so what
rule what do we call it
when you do this to it without having no
expansion has taken place what do we
call it
there's two names so you've got like
lots of options anyone yeah
say it again
ah now we we have left it factorized but
there's a particular rule that we use
when we leave in factorized form to
differentiate just like that does anyone
know it starts with a c
so chain rule is like the lazy short
name of it the other name which is
actually quite handy you may or may not
have encountered it but i'm going to
write it down and if you've never heard
this before you should also write it
down
it's also called the function
of a function rule
now the reason why you may not have
heard this name much is because well
chain rule's so much easier and faster
to say but i'm going to tell you in
about six minutes why this is actually
really helpful to know as a secondary
name okay
does it look good does that look like
the derivative for question two
happy
seven times this is going to be three x
squared so 7 times 3 gives you the 21.
reduce the power i'm also pretty happy
with that
okay now question three are throwing a
curveball at you for three and also for
five
before you differentiate there's
something you should do first
what did you do for question three you
can also see it in the way that the um
the solution has been written what was
changed anyone michael
very good so i've given it to you as a
fraction
and this has been changed into an index
hi mrs ferguson are you after someone
okay
now even though i'm very happy that it's
just answers here i actually would like
to see that working here and if you
don't have this line of working as your
one before this please check it because
it's a really important line rewriting
this in index form you would write it as
f of t and i just threw another variable
at you just to see if you're okay with
that
is equal to what how would we rewrite
that
any takers
all right nicely done okay so this is
the way that we would write this in
index form the way i used to remember it
is that when you cross the line you
change the sign so negative index there
is is division okay and then from here i
can then go to the next line being all
right let's go and differentiate right
does it look good
see that minus sign do you see where it
came from
came from here right where did this 2
come from
because it was uh
because it hasn't already has a minus
one it's minus yeah very good every time
we differentiate the power is going down
it's going down it's going down it's
gone from negative one down to negative
two okay that's it happy times and of
course um we've gone back to it was
really nice to go back to fractional
form because that's what they gave it to
us in rather than in widow negative
index form okay
question four
this again just like question two
there's like a rule behind us anyone
remember what it's called
product rule because it's written as
something times something how else could
you have done it if you couldn't
remember product rule how else could you
have done that question
yeah just expand it out and you'll get
something just like question one and
you're good to go okay now i walked
around and i saw a few people wrong
color i saw a few people struggling a
little bit to remember the product rule
so if you've got something times
something else right we designate each
of the products we give them a name call
one u
call one v
and then your derivative if you're
differentiating this
whatever this happens to be the way i
learned it which is kind of just nice
and easy to say is that it's a
vove v
u dash plus u
v dash you just say it aloud v
which just sounds ridiculous and will
hopefully help you remember it for next
time right so you know what your v is
you can work out what u dash is by
looking at this
thanks man
now you're fine takes it
and then you can work out the other
pieces as you go okay do you end up with
this after you collect all your like
terms
yeah
i'm getting some like
can i get a show of hands who got this
yes did you write it
how about we let's
you you did you got agreement though
okay well i'm not getting convincing who
got a different answer hands up
sounds like we should do this one
together okay let's have a go
what do we got here so i'm going to
write it at the top hopefully let's give
some space so i'm differentiating
x squared minus 3 times x cubed
plus x does that look great did i get it
right yeah okay i mean i'm just writing
the question hopefully i got it right
i'm going to do my v u dash and then my
u v dash i'm gonna do it all in line
hopefully we can get this right but to
help me if you don't have like different
colored pens in your um in your pencil
case can i highly encourage you to get
some because it will help you see
through what you're doing a lot more
easily okay
so here it comes v
and then u dash this is v i'm just
writing it
as given
can you tell me what u dash is
differentiation of u the derivative of u
which in this case is just
2x
to
v
u dash done okay so then i'm going to
add in
do it in the other order i've done v u
dash let's do u
v dash here's u no changes
and then v dash you're gonna have to
help me again this time
open a bracket what do we get
three x squared plus
one
are you happy with that okay now i'm
just going to pause for a minute at this
point you've differentiated
like that's all i that's all i asked you
to do right so strictly speaking you're
kind of done now but i know reflexively
most of you are like
what a mess though right now someone
asked me before like how should i
simplify this okay now i just want to
put a peg in the sand we'll return to
this question
multiple times in the next couple of
weeks right this word simplify
simplify means different things in
different contexts and that's really a
little bit confusing for example
this is expanded would you agree no
brackets anymore
this is some version of factorized was
the word we used before which one is
simpler
expanded
or factorized
now i i'm interested a lot of you sort
of instinctively go to factorize even
though this is expanded and that looks
okay to me short answer is i'm going to
return to this and i need you to think
about why
sometimes it is simpler to be expanded
and other times it's simpler to be
factorized why is it one or the other
we'll come back to that question a bit
later on
i am going to expand here so that i can
collect like terms can you see that
might be useful to me right
let's have a look here 2 x to the 4 plus
2
does that look okay up there
this one's going to take me a little
more work but it's still doable right
i'll do x squared first so that gives me
3x to the 4
plus x squared
and then i'll do the minus three now so
minus nine x squared minus three
how do you feel about my expansion does
it look okay to you i missed anything
you're right
okay again power of colors let's look
for the like terms here right is there
anything i like with 2x to the four
there is right can you tell me what term
it is
there's a 3x to the four right there
okay so does that check out with what we
were hoping for
cool i'm happy with that good
x cubed terms
x cubed terms do i have any x cubed
terms
i didn't catch any so it looks like
something is going on here which makes
me wonder okay what happened with our
expansion clearly something was
happening there that i need to watch for
what's next x squared
one two
three x squared terms
when you collapse them together how many
are you getting
there's three here take away nine minus
six
x squared i'm starting to write things
down or rather think things that i
haven't written
five x to the four
minus
six x squared what's left
just the take away three
i'm done okay now it's worth noting
right you can see this minus nine x
squared that came from somewhere right
so obviously this 2x cube must have been
something to do with a factorization or
expansion that went a little bit wrong
and i'm highlighting this i don't know
who did this by the way who wrote it and
i don't actually need to know but for us
mathematically it is just as important
if not more off you go you're fine
to be able to spot an error and be able
to back our way out of it and know
what's right
as well as to just get the right answer
first off right so this is really
important for us to go through this
all right let's do the rest of it just a
little bit quicker question five i said
we had to rewrite this
square root of x do the same thing as
you did in question three what is that
trick that we pulled
say it again later say it again
okay we can write it as index form x to
the power of a half like so okay so i'm
going to put that actually in here
because this
means differentiate whatever's about to
come right and then do we get minus root
x on 2.
now this is really interesting because
again these errors really help us
understand this is a very common error i
see this all the time so whoever wrote
this you're in good company okay
what do you think was the error that got
made here any suggestions what do you
think
yeah did it didn't reciprocate like
what's going on with this right so in
fact when we subtract one when i
differentiate this right
look at how close a result we get okay
that power comes out the front
that actually looks really good
half but then i reduce the power by 1
and that looks like a square root of x
right it is a square root of x but it's
a square root of x on the
denominator yes so in fact we don't have
to do much to this to change it to be
right
right
i think this
should belong on the bottom
is there another change we need to make
yeah that that well yes the one on the
top and then
that minus sign actually we don't need
to worry about wait good it's like this
minus sign it's that negative index okay
all right happy times and then i left
finally enough the easiest one to last
are you happy with that derivative
cool i was actually surprised when i
said like hey guys come up and write
something on board i was surprised
someone didn't just go to this one first
and just said i'm done okay